breaking news from overnight a lawsuit
filed against prince andrew the latest
from our royal correspondent on that
class a big day for students with
a-level results due but lots of
questions over great inflation and a
lack of university places the education
secretary gavin williamson on the
program very shortly also
all these army marches on come on ollie
speak to the father who has made it his
mission to get a defibrillator into
every school after the sudden death of
his young boy plus the former footballer
jamie carragher who is helping him with
that project and
we speak to the owner of geronimo the
alpaca there he is as well as her
supporter the prime minister's father
stanley johnson on the programme as
officials continue to insist he must be
destroyed it's tuesday the 10th of
august no comment prince andrew's
representatives respond after a lawsuit
is filed in the u.s accusing him of
sexually abusing virginia giffrey
it's a level results day but warnings of
inflated grades and universities under
pressure thanks to a system disrupted in
the pandemic
i'm in grimsby with students eagerly
awaiting results
[Music]
scottish results so to today around 9
30. national fives hires and advanced
hires i'm at edinburgh napier university
as clearing begins the pressure's on for
university places
i'm in greece where the prime minister
has called fires here on the island of
evia something that darkens the hearts
of us all he has also apologized for any
failings in the government response
good morning here in the uk in ireland
things a little bit quieter on the
weather front fewer showers than recent
days a little bit more in the way of
sunshine and feeling a touch warmer too
with lighter winds i'll bring you all
the details through the morning
[Music]
hunger strike day four we're here with
the gurkhas striking at the heart of
government over their poor pensions
we need equal rights we need equal
rights immediately need to address if
you don't want to address maybe tomorrow
maybe after tomorrow we're gonna die
[Music]
good morning we start with the big
breaking news from overnight a lawsuit
has been filed in the u.s accusing
prince andrew of alleged sexual abuse
virginia duffrey has accused the prince
of sexually abusing her when she was
just 17 years old she claims the
incidents took place in london new york
and the u.s virgin islands nearly 20
years ago last night a spokesperson for
the prince who has always categorically
denied the claims tell sky news they had
no comment on the allegations our u.s
correspondent martha kelner reports
it's the picture which continues to
haunt prince andrew and virginia's
euphrates say she won't let him forget
he knows exactly what he's done and
i hope he comes clean about it
dufrese has long claimed she was forced
into sex with the duke of york while
under age something he has long denied
but zhu frey is now suing him in a new
york court she claims convicted
pedophile geoffrey epstein loaned her
out to the prince on three occasions
in new york london and the u.s virgin
islands
in a statement she says i'm holding
prince andrew accountable for what he
did to me my family comes first and i
know that this action will subject me to
further attacks by prince andrew and his
surrogates but i knew if i did not
pursue this action i would be letting
them and victims everywhere down
this case has tormented the prince for
years and been a public relations
disaster for the royal family including
this interview where he denied ever
meetings you frey
i don't remember
that photograph ever being taken we
can't be certain as to whether or not
that's my hand on on her
whatever it is left left side
prince andrew's office haven't commented
on the legal action he's already stepped
aside from public duties but this
scandal continues to loom large over the
palace
martha kellner sky news
we're speaking to our royal
correspondent in the next hour on that
story here on the breakfast show on sky
news um before all of that though um
many of you will be uh very aware of
this this morning nervous start of the
day for a level b tech and scottish
higher students who are waiting to
receive their exam results but there's
warnings of great inflation and pressure
for university places
becky johnson is at a college in
staffordshire for us and james matthews
joins us from edinburgh napier
university hello to you both ladies
first becky what's the plan
well of course these pupils have had two
years of huge disruption to their
education and this year of course didn't
have to sit the normal exams the grades
are based on teacher assessments so
things like assessments set by the
school itself mock exams coursework have
all fed into this now last year we had
the chaos didn't we have that algorithm
being applied and then that government
u-turn that meant it reverted to teacher
assessment and what we saw was actually
an inflation in grades so around
two-fifths of pupils getting a's and
a-stars last year so that was
up from around 25
the year before so we are expecting this
year again to see uh high grades now if
there is that grade inflation that is
going to put huge pressure on university
places and that is the fear really for
pupils who might miss out on the grades
that they're expecting that so many
university places
will have been achieved by pupils that
there won't be those places available
through clearing on competitive courses
look schools say they've worked really
hard to get these grades accurate around
one in five schools have had the grades
that they have awarded checked by exam
boards and we wait to see the results
later this morning
and james a similar situation where you
are
yeah what's different this year of
course in terms of how the assessments
have been handled okay that after the
the shambles of last year 125 000 pupils
had their results downgraded there was
the the posh code lottery uh in scotland
and the scottish government u-turn on
how those results were dealt with it has
been different this year similar picture
really to south of the border attainment
has been measured uh really by teacher
judgments in combination with classroom
assessments but there has been criticism
this year to parents groups some
teaching unions saying that those
classroom assessments amount to exams
and all but name and exams for peoples
who have not had proper time to prepare
for them i'm at edinburgh napier
university they are starting
their telephone clearing lines right now
some courses more popular than others
nursing i can tell you in common with
other places around the country there
are no places for nursing uh on in terms
of the the the curriculum at this place
a very popular subject in the wake of
the pandemic i know we're going to chat
to both of you throughout the course of
the morning thanks very much indeed for
now let's put some of those points uh
should we to the education secretary
gavin williamson who's joining us now
good morning mr williamson thank you for
joining us we don't often see you so
it's a pleasure to have you in the
studio um the institute for government
reports says the most unforgivable
aspect of what happened is that after
canceling exams in 2020 you didn't make
any contingency plans for 2021. why not
we did make contingency plans all the
way from the sort of a september period
all the way up to the christmas period
that's why when we had to make the
really difficult decision uh to not
proceed
with exams and that was a result of a
second education lockdown in january uh
that within literally a few days we
launched the largest consultation the
department and of course
ever have ever launched with over a
hundred thousand responses and we are
ready to go in order to be able to sort
of do that but our favorite approach had
been through examination and that's why
uh in the previous year we'd consulted
extensively as to what that examination
process looked like as we very much
planned in 2021 uh to be making that
assessments uh through examinations they
say you refuse to even entertain the
idea that exams might have to be
cancelled leaving pupils and teachers
completely in the dark well that's just
simply not the case and you'll probably
recall actually that we
made a statement as soon as it was
announced that
schools wouldn't be
able to continue in their usual pattern
literally that same week we made a
statement to the house of commons we
gave absolute clarity that we're moving
to teacher assessed grades and that was
followed by an extensive consultation
that's how that was to be delivered
months later than when you could have
made a decision uh well actually we as
you'll recall the decision to sort of
close schools was um
sort of our sort of on the fifth of
january if i recall and we immediately
sort of followed that up uh with the
announcement as to what we were going to
be replacing uh exams with followed by
the consultation hadn't they they'd
missed the christmas term
no they hadn't so what they'd still done
is had the benefits of a brilliant
education in the classroom and you know
it's obviously right that we sort of
consort on these measures but you know
obviously as a preferred method of
assessment we would always rather go
through the process of examinations
as against teacher assessed grades but
we were always uh clear and we've been
working extensively
myself and my junior ministers
nick gibb and others in order to be able
to have contingency plans uh there and
ready to go which of course we did so
what are the contingency plans for next
year yeah so
we you're probably already aware that
sort of in the last academic year we've
conducted an extensive consultations
move back to examinations
and in the um you know in a few sort of
weeks time as we uh go back into the
sort of uh the winter sort of uh period
we'll be doing another extensive
consultations to the contingency
which will be largely based around
teacher assessed grades but we'd very
much hope that we'll be moving to a
system of where we're able to move into
the more normal pattern of examinations
from next year but always conscious that
there's
this pandemic we've not always been able
to predict the course of it it's
continuously changed and it's absolutely
right that we have
uh contingencies there as we always do
so are you ruling out uh teacher
assessment for this time next year or
well what we're saying is you'll
probably have seen our consultation in
the last academic year we're very much
planning to move back to examinations as
a form of assessment
but we always have to have a contingency
plan in place and that's why
that's why we'll be consulting
in the next academic year on those plans
yeah the reason i'm asking is because
i'm
reading around this story this morning
in more detail it's been the most
disruptive period in children's
education since the second world war and
yet kids are getting record a level
results it looks as though that's going
to happen that will be confirmed later
on so so why is that why are they doing
so well with their a levels if they've
been so disrupted is it done to you well
i think we should start off by
congratulating all children right across
the country for amazing work they've
done i think they've done work
tirelessly uh throughout not just the
last two years but this is a culmination
of 13 years in education i think we
should be
incredibly proud of their achievements
incredibly proud of the grace that they
achieve and you know so many children
hundreds of thousands of children at 8
30 this morning we'll be uh opening up
to see what results that they get and
recognizing that this is the route to
the next stage of their lives whether
that's off to university whether that's
into an apprenticeship a world of work
or other forms of higher technical
qualifications so it is about it is
about success and we should be
celebrating that successfully how do you
employ how do employers choose who the
best candidate is if you know half of
the kids have got a's and a stars well
children have got a broad range of
grades all the way through and you know
it wouldn't be right to sort of preempt
that data that sort of comes out before
children have had the opportunity to see
what grades they have themselves
but um
but what we have i have allowed you to
speak quite a lot
if i may um if for example there are a
lot of a's and a stars which is what is
predicted how do employers choose who
the best candidate is well we see we
have one of the best education systems
in the country we do have a rigorous
system
of grading and awarding
people have been awarded this grade on
the basis of evidence and we took a a
difficult decision
and that decision was um children were
to be assessed on what they'd been
taught
because
children have been incest on what
they've been taught and they'd
we have seen various amounts of
disruption around the country and
children's experience have been a
different you know i've seen with my own
children they've had to sort of
self-isolate
for periods of time others have had to
do less so so it's important that that
assessment was made and what they've
been taught but still you have a very
clear grading system you still see
children who are achieving a stars a's
b's of re c's have really achieved so
very very much and i think employers can
have real confidence in the grades they
get but let's not forget this is an
unprecedented year this is a year like
because we have last year
uh we've had a year like no other but
actually we haven't because we had it
last year as well but actually if you
see the sort of the children that um you
know worked through the system last year
they had the very final part of their
education disrupted where children as
they're coming through to receive their
grades this year they saw disruption at
the end of uh year 12 then they saw more
and further disruption as part of their
year year 13. um
prepare and we
because you wouldn't accept that
potentially this had to happen we
had one of the largest rollouts in terms
of technology anywhere in europe with
distribution 1.3 million laptops we had
contingency plans there and ready to go
in terms of different forms of
assessment i'm glad you mentioned the
laptops do you think it's appropriate
that kids are still uh learning um
online if they're going to university
and yet still paying nine grand a year
would you be happy for that with your
kids uh well we've made it clear that
all universities can move back to
face-to-face teaching that's what we
want to see
we're seeing universities moving to that
with tutorials we also expect that to be
sort of replicated in the lecture
theater as well
well
universities are autonomous institutions
our guidance is clear our direction is
clear and we do expect all universities
unless there's unprecedented reasons to
be moving back to the situation of
actually delivering
lessons lectures face to face and if
they don't should there be refunds for
those kids well i think universities
have got to sort of stand up their offer
to their own students i think that they
have the flexibility and the ability to
deliver face-to-face lectures i'd expect
them to be delivering uh face-to-face
lectures well they are autonomous
institutions i don't have control over
them but um but my question is
we would expect uh we would expect a
university to delivering a high quality
teaching experience and part of that is
actually doing face-to-face lectures and
if they don't should there be a refund
for those well
universities have got to stand up their
offer to their students but we've got
the office for students which is
targeting universities which have low
quality courses which aren't doing
enough and we'll give the ofs all the
power all the backing in order to pursue
those universities that aren't
delivering enough for students that are
paying their fees and because for
government
minister what do you think well i think
if
universities are not delivering
not delivering what students expect then
actually they shouldn't be charging the
full fees of what they're done
thank you for the clarification on that
what about incentives i believe that
extra university is preparing to pay
some medicine offers holders 10 000
pounds to defer to next year because
they've got too many students is that a
good idea okay that's a really
interesting point that you raise and
actually every year as you're well aware
universities have policies of deferrals
with students so this isn't something
that's new or unusual
so we expect to see that within the
university system where
universities want to manage their places
and manage their student inflow but as
part of that we've been working with
universities to make changes we've
increased the number of medical student
places just a few years ago that stood
at six thousand this year is going to
stand just below eight and a half
thousand because we want to maximize the
number of youngsters who are going into
the sort of system uh learning medicine
and then uh
hopefully going into our nhs i want to
ask you about something if i may which
is your previous brief and you will have
seen and this is a subject that has
really distressed a lot of my viewers
and i'm sure that you are as well three
um goku gentlemen are starving
themselves they say to death in
whitehall over their pension parity with
british soldiers they want to meet
the prime minister they say they're
willing to die he won't meet them
we can't let them die can we of course
we can't and we've always got to do
absolutely everything we can do
for our veterans and those who've served
and i remember in my time and the great
privilege of working with the gurkha
regiments and seeing the amazing work
they do
i have no doubt the government has
already made considerable changes to
pensions and gurkha pensions
which was uh which was an important
change and a significant change and i
know that the government always keeps
these matters under review on a regular
basis and secretary would you meet them
if it meant that if you didn't they
would die well no one wants to you know
as every stage
at every stage uh ben the whole team at
the mod
everyone in government uh is there to
support our veterans that's why we have
the armed forces covenanted
in whitehall they just want to be heard
they want they want the defense
secretary to talk to them if you were
defense secretary would you go and talk
to them well as defense secretary you're
regularly speaking to veterans all the
time and i'm i'm sure ben uh will also
be speaking to lots of veterans all the
time because that's what defense
secretary i'm asking you the question
would you go and talk to them if it
meant that it would save their lives
of course we do everything in order to
save people's lives uh no one would go
uh further than uh you know anyone you
know such as the defense secretary in
order to be able to preserve lives and
also to preserve and support veterans as
as a former veteran himself i know that
ben puts an enormous value on this which
was an enormous value in terms of
gurkha regiment that's why it's been
you know
expanded and grown in uh recent years uh
because we we recognize their sort of
unfailing loyalty their failing
commitment that's why we made changes to
the pension regime and pass and uh
that's why all these matters are always
kept on track these are pensioners on
the pavement not eating in whitehall
literally it's it's outside the door you
say that you know if if it were you and
and given ben's a former veteran then uh
the defense secretary he will talk to
them let's hope that he does before it's
too late thank you for joining us on the
program appreciate it uh
zaheed is at the protest in whitehall
for us now hello to aisha how are they
doing
well they're dave on day four of their
hunger strike they're set up just behind
me and just to put it into context the
entrance to downing street is just there
opposite the road and they really want
government action to be taken one of the
veterans uh named dan gurung told us
that at the hands of the british
government
gurkhas have faced 206 years of
historical injustices they've been a
part of the british army since 1815
but those who retired before 1997
haven't been eligible for that uk armed
forces pension in case they've got the
gurkhas pension scheme which is designed
for those who retire and then head back
to nepal where of course the cost of
living is significantly lower
and many gurkhas were able to settle
here in the uk after a change in policy
in 2009 so they want boris johnson to
come out invite them to listen to their
what they need and what action they want
taken we heard words from that there
from gavin williamson yesterday we heard
from quasi uh teng about saying he
thought he said he felt sad that they
feel like this but that's just words
they really want the government to come
out listen to them and take action and
they've said they will be continuing the
hunger strike until they die if that's
what it takes
thank you aisha thank you um
we've been chatting to the gurkhas every
day during their hunger strike as i said
they're just on the pavement in
whitehall some terrible weather here in
london overnight i spoke to dan
yesterday we'll be speaking to him again
later on today and this is what he told
me yesterday
our ancestors they've given lives in
order to save the great britain now we
are fighting for the equal right we need
equal rights we need equal rights
immediately need to address if you don't
want to address maybe tomorrow maybe day
after tomorrow we're gonna die this
response this responsible must be
checked by the british government
as i said we'll be speaking to uh dan
and uh two other gurkhas who are also um
hunger striking on the pavement of
whitehole just down from downing street
later on on the program then at half
past seven i'm going to be uh speaking
to the owner of geronimo the alpaca plus
the father of the prime minister stanley
johnson who is supporting the campaign
to prevent geronimo being destroyed
of the air level results are released
we'll be joined by the shadow schools
minister peter carl that's at five past
eight
and we're still short of thousands of
lorry drivers that's according to the
rhode haulage association who will be
here at 8 20 this morning
[Music]
one of the biggest shows leading the
reopening of the london's west end has
been hit by coronavirus the musical
joseph and the amazing technicolor
dreamcoat has council shows this week
after a member of staff tested positive
let's bring in the latest data for the
uk should we there have been a further
21 25 000 new cases of coronavirus
reported in the latest 24-hour period
slightly down on sunday's figure a
further 37 people have sadly died after
contracting covid that takes the total
number of people who've died within 28
days of a positive test to more than 130
000
and looking at the government's
vaccination program another almost 23
000 first doses of covid have been uh
covered vaccine have been given while
another 122 000 people receive their
second dose in total almost 40 million
people are now fully vaccinated against
covid 19.
official figures show a record number of
pregnant women were admitted to
intensive care with kovid last month it
comes as doctors have warned about
so-called vaccine hesitancy among
expectant moms
talk about the climate now firefighters
in greece are into their eighth day of
battling against huge wildfires there
the country's prime minister has
described the blaze as a natural
disaster of unprecedented proportions
well joining us now is our europe
correspondent michelle clifford she's on
the island of evia forest hello to
michelle what's it like there this
morning good morning
well still significant problems here kay
as you mentioned we're on evia and from
this spot on a sunny morning you'd
normally be able to see the mainland
absolutely clearly but there is still
heavy uh cloud ash cloud and smoke in
the air there's still a significant
blaze on the north of the island you
mentioned the prime minister there he
has described what's happened on evia as
something that darkens the souls of us
all and he's also
apologized for any government failings i
think that those words will ring hollow
with many people who live on this island
there is a great deal of anger because
many people living in villages that had
to be evacuated and were eventually
burned said that uh not enough help uh
came soon enough we saw people yesterday
using buckets to try and put out major
fires around houses overnight
in one village
people formed a human chain just to try
and keep the flames back now what people
told us is a fire crews did come to some
of the villages as far approached the
priority was to get people out that is
understandable but they said they should
have been
much more help help is coming now
there are fire fighters and equipment
from coming coming from nations across
europe and much further afield
okay michelle thank you very much indeed
thanks a lot
uh we want to bring you these pictures
of rescuers who are battling wildfires
in bolivia as well uh as they tackle the
blaze fire fighters discovered this
armadillo look suffering from the
effects of smoke and heat thousands of
hectares of land in the santa cruz area
are at risk of being destroyed the area
is renowned for being home to a range of
wildfires so far more than a hundred
thousand hectares of forest have been
destroyed looking at the weather for you
now here and kirsty is standing by
pretty chilly this morning kirsty what's
the forecast
morning kay yes it was a wee bit chilly
first thing it's a quieter spell of
weather today so for many a better
picture it's drier with more and more
sunshine but the weather does remain
rather cool and changeable this week
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning for many of us today is a
quieter day we'll see more in the way of
sunshine and fewer showers
not completely dry though there will be
some showers developing through the day
especially across eastern parts of the
uk eastern scotland could see some heavy
and thundery downpours but for most the
showers will be lighter than recent days
a bit more in the way of sunshine
lighter winds as well so feeling warmer
23 or 24 celsius the top temperature
through the evening any showers tend to
fade away they do linger for time across
northeast scotland and then a largely
dry night for much of britain but
cloudier skies moving in across northern
ireland and the republic rain coming in
from the west and that rain will push
eastwards on wednesday
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and the last few days have seen heavy
rain across the country but it seems
nothing will stop some people from
eating out well-known italian
restaurants you say these in glasgow
posted this picture on social media
yesterday shows one man at a table
during a typical scottish light rain
shower the restaurant tweeted the
gent-seated ordered a plate of spaghetti
mongolia amaretti and dessert
only in glasgow
i think we've got the sandbag stuff as
you can see uh still to come geronimo
the alpaca
here he is
he still faces the threat of destruction
we'll speak to his owner and the father
of the prime minister stanley johnson
who's trying to save him stay tuned
[Music]
let me tell you what you might have
missed if you've only just joined us
it's the education secretary he's told
us he expects universities to give
refunds to students who don't get
face-to-face teaching wow there are
concerns many courses are still taking
place online following the pandemic but
a short time ago gavin williamson told
this program that classes should be
taught in person or a refund
universities are autonomous institutions
our guidance is clear our direction is
clear and we do expect all universities
unless there's unprecedented reasons to
be moving back to the situation of
actually delivering
lessons lectures face to face
universities have got to stand up their
offer to their students but we've got
the office for students which is
targeting universities which have low
quality courses which aren't doing
enough and we'll give the ofs all the
power all the backing in order to pursue
those universities that aren't
delivering enough for students that are
paying their fees and because for
government
minister what do you think well i think
if
universities are not delivering
not delivering what students expect then
actually they shouldn't be charging the
full fees of what they're done
wow tomorrow i didn't expect him to say
that
no and there's great concern about the
fact that universities of course moved
to online teaching during the pandemic
are now not reversing that decision and
going back to lectures and the education
secretary thinks that that makes it
difficult for students to do their
courses in the way they did before and
of course to get their money's worth now
gavin williamson does not run
universities they run themselves but the
government set up a new regulator to
give value for money to students this
was in the wake of labor saying that
they might abolish tuition fees
altogether a lot of focus on whether
students were getting very much for
their 9 000 pounds a year and now he's
saying he wants that office to have the
powers to pursue those universities and
potentially cut money uh from those
courses which are not giving the
students what he describes as the full
experience of course another big issue
for universities today is what we expect
to be record a level results and how on
earth they choose between students who
are expected to get lot high numbers of
a's and a star grades yeah and what did
he think what did he have to say about
that well not much contrition from gavin
williamson given that a number of uh
independent reports have found that he
failed to plan for this students were
left in the dark for months about what
they'd be assessed on and how
he disputed all of it even though this
is according to officials in his own uh
department who spoke to the institute
for government last week the grades will
be assessed by teachers of course
students will get them in a couple of
hours time and we wish them all the luck
but he said that he he claims he did
plan and that potentially even next year
this might happen again
yeah okay for now thanks so much and do
yeah if you are waiting for your a-level
results this morning on behalf of both
fingers crossed i'm sure you'll do
really really well um and let's find out
about some kids that are waiting for the
exam results becky cottrell is at a
school in grimsby for us this morning
hello to you becky a very good morning
always a nail-biting time
yeah it is indeed here the school is
waiting for the students to arrive
they're coming in shortly
students are expected to get higher
grades this year more kids getting those
top a and a star grades the teachers
like last year have been the ones
awarding those grades they've done that
through in-class assessment and mock
exams and there's been concern that they
might be slightly generous towards the
children but i'm here with the assistant
principal here at havelock academy
joanne woodhouse you say that isn't the
case teachers haven't been extra
generous no absolutely not i think the
we've known for a long time that our
year 13 cohort is a very strong cohort
we've known them for seven years this is
the end of their havelock journey um and
we've known throughout this period that
this has always been a strong cohort so
we were expecting
a good set of results and you've said
you've been extra rigorous with that
process absolutely absolutely it's
really important to us that the grades
that the students receive today um are
justified for them um and the process
has been incredibly robust thank you yes
and the big concern actually is that
there will be a race for places in that
clearing process the students are being
encouraged to not delay when it comes to
accepting their places for university
okay uh becky thanks very much indeed
we'll chat to you throughout the course
of the show thank you um if you're
expecting your a-level results this
morning you'll be fine just breathe just
breathe it'll all be fine
now then uh let's talk about geronimo
should we despite a protest by human
rights campaigners the government is
still insisting that the alpaca must be
destroyed he's a six-year-old animal you
know he's twice tested positive for
bovine tuberculosis uh joining us now is
helen mcdonald she's jonatha's owner she
was chatting to us um at the end of last
week with us again now um hello to you
helen quite a lot has happened since we
chatted to you last week not least the
police have been uh there's been a march
on whitehall what does if anything has
this difference as that made to geronimo
please
um it's yeah it's all been going on um
yeah we've got well i've made your
attention now um we are still here
asking the government to uh accept that
the tests that john and i had four years
ago were wrong um the evidence does not
support
a suspicion of disease um that's very
clear that what's coming out from
government is inaccurate um and that's
been challenged by the british alpaca
society who released a statement last
night um
yeah the march yesterday was fantastic
the support's growing we've got support
from cattle farmers from all livestock
sectors yeah you know
they don't have to kill him
we um your vet was properly strong
wasn't he against george eustis
yes yes but we haven't seen any factual
information coming out recently and
certainly not for the last four years
they're still
misquoting data on on the test that they
claim is highly accurate and suspicious
and specific but they don't take into
account multiple priming with tuberculin
and that's always been the issue
500 i'm being told 500 cattle a day
slaughtered in england um
why should um
geronimo survive i suppose the argument
would be when 500 cattle a day have to
be slaughtered because of tb
yeah my favorite question um
geronimo was was by their own words
treated exceptionally they deviated from
protocols which um i i should not have
been subjected to they had they have a
system for cattle and as far as i'm
aware they use that system what's
happening here is an abuse of power
within government to manipulate the
situation
um and that's what's wrong here it's
it's not a
it's not about comparing cattle and
alpacas they're different species but
we're all on the same side and we all
want fair testing we want scientific
testing this is a voluntary scheme for
healthy animals and so the issue is we
can't trust the system and voluntary
testing is in great danger of actually
just not happening now so there's a huge
knock-on effect for
disease control which is actually what
the government wants
it just doesn't make any sense yeah
what's the timeline helen what are you
being told
i haven't been told anything do you know
if nobody has had the concept of
courtesy in government to pick up the
phone george youssef hasn't spoken to me
in or sent me any information in three
years uh christine middlemen could pick
up the phone we could have a
conversation that has not happened my
lawyers have sent him a letter yesterday
afternoon
and we hope that there will be a
response to that letter today geronimo
doesn't have to be killed he can be kept
in isolation for research and that's
effectively what's been happening for
four years um that is in the power of
the secretary of state to do that um so
this is this is a real sort of knee-jerk
reaction to the fact that you know they
misused the test four years ago it just
yeah it's senseless really
are you still under the impression that
he will be killed you just don't know
when that's going to happen
i don't yeah i mean i'm not being told
anything they have a they have an order
to to come into the property and and
take geronimo and kill him um
but you know what are they doing they're
just i'm hanging around waiting for
something to happen and communication
keeps coming out which is so inaccurate
um
it beggars belief to be honest um and
you know i've been in a situation for
four years
just asking for fair treatment like
everyone else is getting so yeah i'm not
i'm not asking for favoritism and i'm
not i'm not trying to distinguish myself
or camelots from from cattle situation
but the reality is genre came from a
healthy farm in new zealand
they've misused a test to make a
suspicion of disease and we are me and
jerome are both victims of government
incompetence
so so helen just to be clear you're
waiting you don't know when they might
come it could be in the middle of the
night could be whenever and you're just
waiting for somebody to come with a big
gun to shoot him
yeah basically i mean the police did say
on friday it wouldn't be in the middle
of the night um but you know they could
come at any time and so we have our our
alpaca angels um here supporting us and
protecting us with trying to get sleep
um it's a very distressing situation and
it's as i said george eustis really
needs to come and justify to me why he's
made this decision without any evidence
and and how we can all move forward
together as a
in a positive way we're very happy to
sit down and discuss how we can learn
from geronimo's case for the benefit of
everyone else in the society and
lifestyle and catholic farmers as well
so you know this issue is not going to
go away if they shoot him it's going to
make it worse okay um well i'm sure
you'll want to stay with us helen uh and
listen to our next guest because um
stanley uh johnson who is a former
conservative mep and supporter of
geronimo also um
i should perhaps mention as an aside the
prime minister's father um hello to
stanley johnson always great to see you
um why are you backing geronimo
well i'm backing
geronimo in the sense that i think he
deserves
another
another test it's it's as simple as that
i
spoke to helen over at the weekend she
explained the situation to me don't
think i in any way
underestimate the importance of
this this issue of the importance of
bovine tuberculosis i come from a
farming background myself i know the
hardship and the anguish which farmers
experience when they are forced to have
their cattle put down there's absolutely
no clear about that but what i'm saying
here
is that
given that that animal has been
alive and apparently thriving for the
last four years given the doubt
that there was as to whether or not this
was a false positive or false or a real
real positive
surely it makes sense to invoke another
test procedure and i think that helen
explained to me
when i spoke to her last last saturday
but yes there is another test which
could be done i think it was called
activage and that might um reveal what
she firmly believes and
certainly the people i've spoken to say
why on earth would a diseased animal
live for another four years
have that test see what the result is it
seems to me not unreasonable in fact
totally reasonable to say look in this
case
that's not some legal procedure which
says because an animal was suspected of
having a disease
four years ago
even though there's no evidence that
still has a disease that animal has to
be killed that's all i'm that's what i'm
saying and i'm certainly not taking an
anti-farming point they have a huge job
to do the um the bits what a pity it is
you might say that we don't actually
inoculate uh our catholics as i
understand it is something to do with
our ability to trade with america we
don't want to have a cattle or meat
which has come from inopulated cars we
might say well why do we have gm gm
america
now this is the issue it's a good issue
and without becoming over emotional i
just think that it is worth taking your
pause and saying there is another test
available that's jewish
um you did say um i think i read an
article that you wrote saying tear up
that threatening letter minister you're
not very impressed with the way george
eustis is dealing with things just at
the moment are you
i'm going back i'm going back four years
i think i'm going back some time and i
was told by evan and she gave me the
text of the letter i didn't give him the
text word for the word it gave me the
gist of the letter which really said
look if you do proceed and have another
test you may be breaking law and if that
is the case
you are liable to prosecution and
possibly going to jail that just seems
to me to be a tough language now
let's be clear
that the minister has a huge number of
things to do the ministers who work with
him
like richard bennion who's a friend of
mine has a huge number of things to do
and he's working hard and harder you
know to make sure that the safety of the
cattle and
the cattle industry in this country is
assured but on this particular case i
think it is worth saying look
have another look
take it take it as far as we can go and
and let's see what the result is with
that in mind have you spoken to your son
about it
no i haven't i haven't i mean i don't
know
whether my son reads the the sun um
i am
i rate this as in my capacity as the
wildlife reporter for the summer
job i'm very happy to have happy to have
you know it's the most wonderful
wonderful thing to do um i don't know
that he reads the song i don't know he
read my article um who can say but at
least i put my view on on the table and
i did so really because i was very
impressed by the lady you've just you've
just heard no of course there's a little
bit of emotion as far as i'm concerned
as well because
oh gosh i guess 18 years old i spent six
months traveling all through south
america from brazil bolivia to peru and
did spend time up in the outer planet
where you saw
the amazing planet by the way is that
straight those stretch of planes high
level planes between the peaks of the
andes and and you will see
the pecunius the llamas the alpacas so i
guess i i had a kind of emotional
reaction when i saw them just just given
that a final question mr johnson if i
made given that you are so passionate
about it i mean do you think it might be
a good idea to perhaps just lift the
phone to your son
no i i don't think it's it's right for
me as
an ordinary citizen to kind of invoke
some privileged access mechanism and
you know say i say
you know in any case that puts him in a
difficult position um
he's got to weigh the evidence george
eustis has to weigh the evidence
people have to weigh away the evidence
and my my opinion is just one of many
opinions but
i feel free to make it
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed for taking the time to join us
from northwest london this morning thank
you
and thank you helen as well
um talking about john involved the
alpaca what is going to happen next
keeping across that story for you also
this one across southern california
towns and villages are waiting to see if
they are next to be hit by the giant
dixie fire officials say it's the
largest single wildfire in the state's
history and now covers around 765 square
miles our u.s correspondent mark stone
is in taylorsville a town that lies in
the predicted path of the fire
well we've been watching firefighters on
the ground and in the air over the
course of the day as they try to
continue to put these blazes out you can
see another helicopter there with water
underneath it it's a
a constant flow as they go back and
forth from the lower ground
to the higher ground to these valleys
where the fire continues to rage we're
just outside the town of greenville a
town that was tragically destroyed late
last week by what's now known as the
dixie fire the largest according to the
governor the largest single fire in
californian history it's been raging for
a month now it continues to rage
greenville tragically is destroyed other
communities are now at risk the the
smaller town of taylorsville is not that
far from here a couple of miles to the
uh to the left of your camera angle
there and the real fear now is that that
small community could well be next and
of course we're only looking at one
small flank
of this huge huge fire and you can watch
there i think you'll be able to see in a
moment uh the water
as it's dropped from underneath
that helicopter you know it feels
at times to be to be futile when you
watch that tiny tiny helicopter and such
a huge
expanse of land that continues to burn
but they're continuing to try to put
this and many other fires across this
part of the united states out
on our regular dashboard uh for you very
familiar with it by now aren't you what
happens real time with the power mix uh
the global warming since 1880 the time
left to reach 1.5 celsius unless we do
something about it and the co2 emissions
more on our top story the publication
this morning of a level b tech and
scottish higher results joining us now
is paul britton the principal at white
sixth form college hello to you good
morning thank you for joining us um
tense time for kids isn't it how are you
feeling
uh i'm feeling really proud thank you
kay um i'm feeling really excited about
these great results that our young
people are going to receive
uh you know and and they worked so
incredibly hard in the face of of real
real challenges through this last year
so yeah i think the main feeling at the
moment is pride um
how do you feel about the fact that they
were teacher assessed rather than
examinations
i think that in the end that was the
best possible solution that we could uh
come up with this year you know our
students haven't been uh having
face-to-face teaching for for about half
of their course um you know they've been
at home they've been kind of trying to
negotiate with their brothers and
sisters about who gets access to the
laptop um and not least they've been
having to face the the fear and the
isolation that comes uh with the
pandemic so i think getting the teachers
to give these grades was was the best
way to do it i think the only thing i
would do differently is i would make
that decision a lot earlier our students
didn't know this was going to happen
that was going to be my next question
after christmas yeah that was going to
be my next question because i did put
that actually i don't if you saw we had
the education secretary on a little bit
earlier on he said that you knew as soon
as was absolutely possible to know
no i think that's just wrong um there
was a lot of delay in the autumn term uh
we were consistently asking for for real
clarity about how students would be
assessed through this year the
government kept saying oh it's going to
be exams it's going to be exams and then
when we had the lockdown after christmas
that was when the inevitable came and
they said it was going to have to be
teacher assessed so
no the big plea i've got this morning is
for our next group of students who are
going into their final examination year
let's give them some certainty about how
those exams are actually going to take
place and let's get that in place for
the start of the year in september i did
also ask him about that he said it did
look at this stage as though it would be
an examination-based system but he
couldn't guarantee it
yeah i mean so that's that's fine i
think we need to share some real clear
parameters i think we all recognize that
if the pandemic kicks off again uh going
into the autumn things may have to
change um but what we need is a kind of
uh a system that is
has the likelihood of working rather
than just kind of sticking slavishly to
the idea that oh well exams are going to
be fine aren't they uh we need something
that's kind of considered discussed with
the with the profession uh and uh is one
that we can share with the students so
they've got a real certainty and with
the caveat that we might have to change
um if there's if there's serious
problems on a national basis okay um
good luck later on mr britain thank you
very much indeed thank you